while more earth tremors have rocked
southern haiti just days after the
devastating earthquake that killed more
than 2 000 people the recovery effort
has been hampered by the recent tropical
storm and by haiti's natural geography
the caribbean nation's horseshoe shape
and the thin flanks of the northern and
southern peninsula have made it
vulnerable in times of natural disasters
now medical supplies food and materials
for shelters are desperately needed
hospitals are sending out pleas for
immediate help
crowded into this hospital room they are
the least able to help themselves
thousands of injured children in haiti
are desperate for care after saturday's
powerful earthquake doctors say the
hospital is urgently short of staff to
tend to all victims
u.n estimates say more than 540 thousand
kids have been affected by the quake
other numbers are equally staggering
according to the haiti civil protection
agency
at least
1941 people died
and over 10 000 people were injured
along with heavy damages to more than 12
000 homes
we have trapped victims and overwhelmed
hospitals
the scenes elsewhere just as bleak
hospitals say they're in immediate need
of more supplies to stop the death toll
from climbing
this woman just lost her daughter at a
hospital in lakay
we came in yesterday afternoon
they couldn't do anything for her they
just gave her a painkiller and she just
died in my arms this morning
haiti's earthquake has left tens of
thousands without shelter
left to sleep in the streets
their suffering was only compounded as
tropical storm grace lashed the region
with heavy winds and rain on monday and
tuesday
now aid is slowly beginning to arrive
but with it anger
over what many see
as broken promises
and misused humanitarian funds after the
last major quake 11 years ago
you